[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 114
over the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I'm Mok Mandal and I'm here with
my colleague Melanie work how are we
doing this fine morning Melanie great
mark how are you doing I'm doing very
well glad to be back in the recording
studio with you today yes it is good to
be back here as well yes today we are
going to be on this very special day we
are going to be actually talking with
two neat and Margaret who are coming
from Microsoft and Google respectively
working in machine learning and AI
research and they're also specifically
here to talk to us about machine
learning bias and fairness and they do a
lot of research around that which we had
a great time talking to them about some
looking forward to that interview
amazing and unfortunate we didn't have
enough time for it but before we get to
that we always do the cool things of the
week and we also have our question at
the end of the podcast which is
basically a chat between mark and a
mutual friend of ours KF and the
question is pretty much that is there a
TCP service that's basically cloud
identity aware proxy except for a static
site that you host via cloud storage so
we'll get into that at the end of the
podcast all right mark what's the cool
thing of the week that's on your mind
cool things the week so I'm gonna go to
the community first rather than one of
our blog posts there is a really cool
medium blog post talking about GPS
cellular asset tracking using Google
Cloud IOT core five store and Mongoose
OS it is written by someone whose name
is I'm unfortunately going to be
completely an utter butcher I'm gonna go
with Alvaro via Brants it's a really
great article that goes into great
technical depth about how they put all
the pieces together shows off a lot of
code on how basically they get
information from the assets themselves
so the mobile devices into IOT core
which then takes them to the pubsub
which then puts things in cloud
functions which then goes in the cloud
fire store which then goes into a web
app based on firebase hosting it's a
really great read I should probably
check that out if any of that sounds
particularly interesting to you yes and
they provide a tutorial on how to do
this as well which is really awesome so
definitely check that out what do you
get all right I have
there are GPUs now involved with
kubernetes engines so basically GPUs in
kubernetes engine is now available in
beta and when you are spinning up
anything with kubernetes engine you can
just set up what kind of GPUs you need
type number and you're good to go sweet
finally I know there are a lot of Java
programmers out there and spring is a
very popular framework so we are
actually announcing spring cloud at GCP
integrating your favorite Java framework
with Google cloud so if you're using a
spring and you want to use a product
like say cloud sequel or cloud pub/sub
or cloud storage or stack driver trace
or the runtime configuration API there's
direct integrations with Spring
Framework such as their JDBC frameworks
bring resources cloud sleuth those sort
of things that are available if you want
to get started there's links to code
samples reference documentation is the
GCB project page as well as having
spring cloud code labs wow that's hard
to say you can also cook too and have a
play with so if spring is your thing oh
that was fun go check that out that's
coming up all right well I think it's
time to go talk with to meet and
Margaret so let's do that
this week's podcast we are excited to
have two neat gabru and Margaret
Mitchell join us to talk about machine
learning fairness they both have
experience and research backgrounds
especially around machine learning
cognitive sciences computer vision
language processing I'm definitely
excited to have them here because
they've been doing some work around bias
and fairness in the machine learning and
AI space that I think would be very
interesting to hear about so welcome
thanks thanks for having us thanks for
having us so to me can you give us a
little more information about your
background sure I have a very roundabout
way of arriving where I am right now
I studied Electrical Engineering at
Stanford and well I'm originally from
Ethiopia was a refugee here I came to
the state's when I was 16 and so then I
went to San Fransisco D Electrical
Engineering and I did analog circuit
design like hardware and I did that for
my mess and then I worked at Apple doing
that designing circuits and things like
this
and then I got a Master
and then somehow I was working and
devised something called device physics
which is then even more of analog
circuit design and somehow I started
getting interested in image processing
and then that became computer vision and
then I just kind of switched my entire
direction to do computer vision in my
PhD and then towards the end of when I
was working on computer vision I was
very very worried about the lack of
diversity in that entire field and just
in AI in general like every time I went
to a conference I would not see women
but also like I would see very very few
black people and then Torcy Anna my PhD
I also read this republic article about
software that's predicting crime
recidivism rates so that started to
worry me and then I decided like I
wanted to spend a little bit of time
trying to understand the societal
impacts of AI and some work of people
who are working on fairness and things
like this like meg has worked on it way
longer than me so that I have joined
Microsoft Research in New York and the
fête group so fate stands for fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
so right now I'm doing a postdoc there
thanks that's great and Margaret your
background I know you're at Google but
you've also had a background with
Microsoft yeah so I am I did my PhD in
computer science focusing on natural
language processing and then I
eventually joined MSR as a researcher
there in the natural language processing
group under Bill Dolan and worked a lot
on language generation which is
producing sort of linguistic
descriptions about the real world my
work was generally grounded in images so
I worked on that while at Microsoft
Research and I was really noticing and
focusing on some of the things that my
systems were starting to generate kind
of as we moved into deep learning the
language that was being generated seemed
more and more human-like and within that
human likeness there were more and more
things that were alarming me and so I
started focusing more and more directly
on a couple things one is how can we
like take the technology we're working
on and put it forward for positive
ethical use cases long term and that was
really focusing on things like
accessibility as well as how can we do
things I can mitigate by
or address problematic human biases and
stereotypes in the data we're training
on so that eventually we don't propagate
or amplify the biases there was an
opportunity for me to really focus on
the ethics part of this at Google and so
after three years I left Microsoft
research and then joined Google to work
directly on fairness and ethics and
machine learning nice I know when I met
both of you you were co-hosting or Co
running an AI ethics group that was made
up of people all different groups all
different companies education
backgrounds and it was a great session
in terms of just talking about some of
the issues that look at the broader
issues I think the main question I want
to ask is you know to just help our
listeners starting out you've touched on
it but can you give us like how to think
about what is ml fairness that's a
really big question so when we talk
about ml fairness we're often talking
about something like prejudice or
stereotypes that are propagated by
algorithmic systems and specifically
machine learning systems there's a lot
of sort of ways to talk about what
fairness is and bias comes in and then
bias can mean a few different things
some of that mathematical some of its
social basically the the fairness world
kind of encompasses a lot of things that
have to do with the diversity and
inclusion in the outputs of our systems
and looking at whether or not there's
disproportional sort of negative effects
or disproportional inaccuracies on some
subgroups corresponding to different
kinds of social groups like race gender
age Thanks and in terms of the work that
you've both done I know you've talked
about the groups that you've been
involved in can you tell us a little bit
more about you know what Google's doing
what Microsoft is doing in these spaces
with ml fairness um I can talk about
what Microsoft is doing is specifically
especially my group so one of the
reasons I joined fate but it's a newly
created group is because it's an
interdisciplinary group so I really
believe that you can address this
problem by just talking to other machine
learning people or by just talking to
other lawyers because
example there are some laws Equal
Employment Opportunity laws for example
that I don't think are being applied to
algorithms like hiring algorithms that
could you know have biased outputs or
things like this so I say there are
people like Kate Crawford Hannah wallop
does machine learning but also
computational social science Jay Wortman
Vaughan and there's also other people
like perfect work with us peripherally
like Glenn who is a very well-known
economist and so what we do is we not
only try to understand the societal
impacts but also then work on some
technical machine learning solutions so
personally like what I've been very
focused on even though what I like to do
most is technical work you know computer
vision or purely machine learning this
year I've been more focused on trying to
uncover some biases that exist in
commercial api's for example that are
being sold to people and then trying to
figure out how to have a standardized
way of providing some sort of
information for people so for example
like from my hardware background I know
that any little component that you use
like from the cheapest resistor to life
something as complicated as a CPU or
something like this
always comes with something called a
datasheet right and so for me I'm trying
to like evangelize this idea of a
datasheet or between models api's and
datasets and trying to understand what
that would look like what the pitfalls
are or you know if we had a datasheet
for this kind of process what it would
look like and trying to talk to other
product groups as well trying to work
with them to see what it would look like
for them if it's useful for them to have
this idea etcetera etc so in addition to
I guess the technical work I'm
personally more focused on trying to
understand policy and what kinds of
standardization we could have and things
like this nice so at Google one of the
things that really really appealed to me
was the ability to work across the
organization and so part of my job now
involves talking to people on who's
working on mobile devices assistant
cloud all these different kinds of
products and services that Google is
offering and talking to them at the
level of code at the level of data like
what's going on that might be amplifying
different kinds of biases and so we're
starting to put out some stuff publicly
I'm specifically focused on machine
learning code that can help mitigate
different kinds of biases we're working
incredibly hard internally across a
variety of different dimensions from
what the UX experience should be like
when you have some sort of bias issue to
what kind of input we want from
different kinds of sources like Tim neat
says like including people from policy
including people who have focused on
ethics philosophically really trying to
dig into this frost disciplinary effort
across Google as as a whole so it's been
a really nice chance for me to try and
make change from within you know working
directly with products that I know are
touching millions or billions of people
and and really walking through like how
can we make this really work for
everyone nice it's nice that there's
both the internal but also like to neat
you're saying you know working this
cross-disciplinary way of looking at you
know how to think about this on a
broader scale - yeah you touched on this
briefly I'm happy to let you all talk
you know any more about this than I do
but Tim you touched on this briefly
about you're talking about sort of
biases and hiring practices I wonder if
you could kind of expand on sort of
maybe some comment or possibly some not
well-known biases that ml can kind of
introduce or what basically some
examples especially for those people who
aren't necessarily as familiar with the
space and I know you've got a research
paper that was out around you know
demographics especially looking at cars
so I know that's one that might probably
be on mind so let me let me answer your
question Anna and a particular way to
bring in something I always want to talk
about which is diversity so this is why
I think diversity is important and it's
basically almost like having domain
knowledge so for example when you know I
I guess this is a well-known example
which is the crime recidivism rates that
I was talking about so there was this
protocol article that talked about how
this company was using machine learning
to predict someone's likelihood of
committing a crime again right so what
I read this article I was immediately
absolutely horrified because I just knew
that there was absolutely no way that
this software would not be biased the
reason is that I've been you know I've
been a black woman in all my life and I
live in the u.s. and I you know know all
sorts of things that happen to my
friends I ain't know also so statistics
for the likelihood of you know being
caught by police if you commit a crime
as a black person versus not in certain
neighborhoods etc so all of these news
just came to my brain when I was reading
about this article and I immediately
even though I have never worked in
fairness before and I didn't even think
before that about this concept of
algorithmic fairness that article for me
was very scary because I had this domain
knowledge that this bias exists because
of my background and because of the
types of things I've been reading about
right so so I guess my point is that
there are many such things where so one
one thing I I learned for example is
that speech recognition does not work
well for younger people but also people
who have hearing impairments or things
like this and I'm not you know in that
community so it's more difficult for me
to know about these biases that someone
has that type of domain knowledge it's
important for me to interface with
someone that has that type of domain
knowledge in order to know about these
biases so for me this issue of bias and
diversity go hand-in-hand and sometimes
I get kind of frustrated when we if we
only talk about the technical aspects
because I just feel like they they go
hand in hand to meet I really hear you
on that and one thing that I think is
really struck me as I've worked on
fairness and I've worked with others on
it is that it's actually really
difficult to work on machine learning
models where you're where you're
recognizing for example that this only
works for pale males or this only works
for men and not women and not see the
same kind of patterns in your everyday
work life I mean ideally these are maybe
two separate worlds but I think for
actually the engineers and researchers
good at seeing these kinds of patterns
we're working on these kinds of patterns
and not seeing them in the world is no
longer an option it's kind of like once
your eyes are open to it then you see it
although they are sort of separate I
think the people who get the most
inspired by it some of the people who
are the most driven are the people who
are seeing the patterns on both sides of
the coin
both in the machine learning you know
machine learn more world as well as
their everyday work life I was also kind
of saying like one of the things I was
thinking about is many of the papers or
the works when we were talking about
machine learning in fairness we don't
look at the data generation process
right I guess there's this more it's
this paper on causality that tries to
look at okay how could this data have
been generated but most of the time we
just kind of take the data and we say
okay given this data what our devices
that exists are in great you know what
notions of fairness can we use this up
and one direction I you know I don't
know how to bring this in like one
direction I really want to think about
is how can you transfer the knowledge
that you have about what types of biases
could exist to your model of how this
data could have been generated and
therefore and what ways it pipi bias so
that maybe you can have knobs like you
know instead of even if you had a crime
recidivism rate model instead of giving
it to some judges and it just spits out
like a probability saying this person
has X likelihood of committing a crime
maybe the judge you know if someone had
a a tool to say okay what if I know that
you know this particular data could have
been biased in a particular way for
example this particular zip code is x
times more heavily police or something
like that what if I can have some knobs
and change what kinds of vices could
exist and then that kind of tells me
what the variance could be for a
particular person like prisons outcome
or something like this I don't know and
so in that case then your knowledge of
the world and society is is very very
useful right and you could transfer it
directly to your work do you think that
there are certain problems that we
should not be solving right now with
machine learning especially based on the
fact that we have bias and our data bias
and the way we're developing I think
that we need to be really careful to
include
the experts and the people who are
really qualified to work on different
problems when we're thinking about using
machine learning and I can give us some
specific examples so one thing is when
we work on machine learning in the
clinical realm or the Health domain one
of the issues that is really difficult
from a pure machine learning perspective
is how to create technology that is
directly useful for clinicians and that
also has some sort of explained ability
for patients and how do you work with
consent around clinician and patient if
you're using machine learning models and
how exactly will this be applied and one
thing that's that's really kind of
struck me about this is that we need to
make sure that as we work on machine
learning in light of diversity and in
light of inclusion include all the
people who this would be directly
affecting and who would potentially be
working with this in order to understand
what the real problems are and bring in
the expertise where where we don't have
it as computer scientists I mean machine
learning is super powerful and it's easy
to get into the thought process where
you feel like you can sort of do
anything like you're you know Superman
or something and that misses the fact
that there are so many nuances and so
many details across so many different
disciplines that you're just going to
overlook when you're only focusing on
the machine learning hammer it's a great
point considering I know there's always
the questions of how you test these out
brothers how do you fully test these
algorithms and that you maybe not fully
but definitely looking at a broader way
to test the algorithms I totally like I
totally do with this because one example
was I was talking to Adam kalaiy about
like some idea I was really excited
about and we just went on the whiteboard
are we writing probabilities and things
like this and then Glenn who's an
economist saying well but the way would
really work in the courts is like
someone would sue someone like this and
he just kind of killed our idea like
that but but it was really interesting
to hear his perspective because I had
absolutely no idea you know what he was
talking about before but he explained it
to me but unless you work with people
like that you're not going to come up
with something that's directly
applicable and you're not going to come
up with something that actually
addresses the
you might come up with a paper that's
cool great but I don't think you're
gonna come up with it was something that
actually addresses the problem great
cool this this is super fascinating I'm
also kind of curious to hear also like
you've touched on it abated like saying
that we don't also need to talk about
the technical side but I'd love to talk
about the technical side too and see is
there solutions on the software side of
things as well or how you build em
models of how you build your data sets
can you talk a little bit about that to
see if there's there's opportunity there
as well to help with bias ease yeah
there's definitely a lot to do we're not
in a situation where we have a silver
bullet or a clear solution but we do
have a lot of things that we can do for
example on the data side by including
sources that are not just those that are
the most easiest or you know most
available to us and actually thinking
about sampling from locations across the
world's different kind of demographic
category it's making sure that what we
do is representative of who we want to
serve and who we want to work with as
opposed to what's that easy access and
this is something that requires like
people who are good at collecting data
from people and which might not be
machine learning scientists necessarily
but might be a whole other sort of
section of expertise but there's a lot
to be done on how to create inclusive
data sets data sets that capture a lot
of different worldviews that aren't
necessarily going to be downloadable
from Flickr or Twitter doing some simple
query searches on the machine learning
side there's a lot of really interesting
work coming out now in this space of
bias mitigation it's also kind of called
unbiased or D biasing which is an over
self that's that's a bit of hype what
we're actually doing when we work with
these models is we take a look at some
sort of known biases some known
stereotypes for example to Nate
mentioned the Co I work associating
woman to homemaker Atwal associating man
to computer programmer these are these
kinds of biases that we can kind of
discover and then build models around in
order to define what is this subspace of
bias
what is this subspace of gender bias for
example and can we do some cool math to
address it doing something like
subtracting it out from our
representations I've been doing some fun
work
Google where we do adversarial
predictions we basically take
predictions on some sensitive attribute
and then negate the gradient that we get
from that in order to force the model to
not be able to make decisions based on
race or based on gender based on
different kinds of sensitive
characteristics there's a lot that is
coming out and can be done on the ml
side there's a lot more to do and I'd
love to see a lot more focus on on the
data side but these are just these are
just starts this is just the start of
something that could be much bigger so
what one thing I was thinking about is
that you know we talk about certain
things like for example I gave the
example of this OpenCV library not
detecting Joyce face right so a lot of
times we talk about diversify our data
sets so even even with our paper joy you
know we we have this diverse data set
more diverse data set so people can test
out their algorithms but you know humans
as a human if I've never seen I know is
this true like if I have never seen a
black person before and I see a black
person for the first time I would
identify them as a black person right I
am as a person like I wouldn't just not
detect their face you know or someone if
I see a new race of some people and
given like all of the data that I've
seen before not being from that race so
I I feel like maybe there is an
opportunity for us to go further than
just purely supervised machine learning
where you know if you don't see it in
your data set then you know it's not
accurate and in order to make it more
accurate you know you need to diversify
your data set I feel like it could help
us have a paradigm shift in how we
approach these types of problems well
and I know there's the value of using
these models especially to think of new
ways to solve problems or think of new
ways to think about things that's you
know that's the real value add though
several of these models have come about
which is touching on what you're talking
about like this unstructured learning
this we try not to tell the model what
to think and try not to influence what
the models should be thinking you should
try to let it kind of us discover on its
own but I know the biggest challenge is
with the data to begin with do you think
that there's still a way to fully pull
out the bias especially when you are you
know working with predictive models that
are doing something that's in relation
to people so one one
that that's interesting is that if we
pick the attribute that what we call
sensitive attributes or I don't know
protective protected classes right so
race gender age disability you know
sexuality religion etc etc etc then I
think we have a better chance because we
can see what the disparities could be
with those things that when you look at
things like health care when you move
into a broader view of things these are
not going to be the only things that you
will have systemic bias and in my
opinion and so then the question will be
I think also how could we discover the
bias that we might have not already know
exists right so even in the work that
meg mentioned they already knew like
they kind of guess that there there
would be a bias right like that
gender-based bias so what about other
attributes that we haven't thought about
right because we're not 100 percent
diverse even if you're well-meaning
there is going to be a bias that you're
not aware of unless you're interacting
with somebody from that part of the
world so so how do we also address those
issues I don't really have the answer to
that but yeah that's a question I'm
thinking about you have to have all the
answers one one thing one thing that is
really useful I'm gonna put a plug here
for this in case there are machine
learning people listening and one thing
that is really useful to do is to take a
look at your false positive rate and
false negative rate and false negative
rate is one - true positive rate so this
is this kind of thing you get from an
ROC curve I think in both NLP and
computer vision there tends to be a
focus on precision recall in NLP f-score
is big envision accuracy as big this
overlooks the kinds of errors that might
disproportionately affect different
kinds of subgroups different kinds of
groups of people and so by having some
focus at least in our classification
systems on what the differences are
in the false negative rate and false
positive rate can give us a sense of how
these things might be underperforming
when we do sort of intersectional
analyses by subgroup that doesn't say
much about like score based systems or
ranking based systems but there is some
basic things that we can do with
given machine learning and statistics
machinery to focus in on some sort of
statistical version of disparate impact
or how things might be affecting some
subgroups worse than others
in our in our current paper we were
analyzing api's right so the api's were
gender classification so they just look
at a face and they you know give you a
binary like male/female label and they
don't give you a probability or anything
like that they just give you the legal
and this does not allow you to adjust
for your particular setting you might
want to have different types of you know
false positive false negative rates and
if you don't get the probability output
you can't you don't have a chance to
adjust this the threshold to the
threshold exactly so this is one
concrete I think step that commercial
api's can take because I'm certainly
very worried about commercial ApS
because at least ok in research you know
you have an understanding that it's
research maybe it's for only the
research community etc these commercial
api's are being used by by so many
different startups so many different
people and who don't know we don't have
any regulation potentially governments
governments to use them there's we don't
have they're not accountable they don't
have to tell us what they're using what
the accuracy is what the characteristics
of the software is for what for which
reasons so I guess I'm bringing it back
to the standardization stuff but I mean
I think this is Meg's example is a great
example of I think the kinds of
information additional information that
these api's need to give us an
interpretability I know that's a huge
one too in terms of understanding what's
really going on inside of the model to
begin with and Mark I want to make sure
you have a chance I knew you had another
question you wanted to ask no no you're
good keep going ok well I think that one
of the other questions and you you both
have touched on this already is what are
some of the other tools in the space
that you you'd recommend that people can
use now to help with their own work in
machine learning and driving fairness so
on my side I can speak to some Google
products and services that I'm actually
kind of excited about and have been
working with a bit so one thing is
facets which is a visualization for ml
data sets it's available on github and
it's a way that you can do different
slice
seeing across different kinds of groups
or subgroups or you know demographic
characteristics in order to see how well
your data or how well your output is
representing each of these different
kinds of groups it's a really handy
visualization tool and you can look at
the effect of different threshold and do
a lot of really cool stuff with it so
that's something that Google has put out
to help on the data side of
understanding some of the possible
biases there's also this thing that's
come out from Google called lattice
which helps with some kind of post op
analyses and interpretability about
different machine learning models
I believe it's publicly called lattice
Google best tensorflow lattice and we're
putting more and more into tensorflow to
help with different kinds of machine
learning problems that can deal with
fairness and bias we're kind of keeping
it really technically focused right now
but creating this kind of code base that
we can share with others to help with
these these kinds of bias and fairness
issues great to meet what about you
oh I would recommend that people check
out the fat star conference that's about
to happen and at the tutorial section
has a whole bunch of tools like just
software to visualize your data and what
kind of discrimination might exist to
pre-process some data some some tools to
help with interpretability so really
like I think a lot of the tutorial is
just about these different tools so I
just recommend that people check those
out joy joy is totally using I'll jump
in real quick you've mentioned joy twice
do you want to talk a little bit about
what that is because I think we talked
about it before the actual podcast
joy is a student at MIT Media Lab who
focuses on face recognition and bias and
face recognition and I consider I mean
this one she's a computer vision person
she keeps some saying that she's not but
so joy is a joy boo LM when a person
saying she has something called the
algorithmic justice lead she even gave a
TED talk I mean when she just started
her PhD and I met her two years ago ish
and we've been collaborating ever since
so our current paper at faster is
actually based on her master's thesis so
she spent a whole bunch of time
analyzing face recognition and she did
this intersectional kind of analysis so
usually you know people just look at I
kept well usually people just look at
aggregate accuracy on some sort of data
set right and then maybe they would
break it down by male female or or race
and so she said okay you don't who can't
just break it down by just gender or
just race or just age you have to look
at the intersection of gender and race
or gender race and age etc etc and then
she also thought you know people have
done this analysis across different
racial groups but Reese as we know is a
very unstable category so you know what
is considered black in the u.s. is very
different from bazzill from South Africa
from Ethiopia etc and it's not even
stable across time so her idea was to
use this more objective metric of skin
tone what's called a fitzpatrick skin
classification system and so analyze
accuracy by the intersection of gender
and and that and also you know other
things so but for this paper it was just
you know gender and so joy has been very
vocal about this she's been working with
various organizations like the I Triple
E to come up the new standard but in
addition to that she also works on just
you know algorithmic fairness from the
you know social standpoint and from the
technical say I mean she does so many
things I can't keep track of all the
things she's doing she also makes like
short movies and as she also raps by the
again diversity for me comes in because
people like her are generally either
turned away from the field of machine
learning or somehow weed out yeah I
think that type of personality is
generally given some sort of subliminal
message that they don't belong in this
environment and we really need to change
the educational system or the marketing
or whatever it is that is kind of
excluding people like her to bring in
people like her because we absolutely
need those types of people in this field
especially when we're talking about
fairness yeah completely agree just be
clear so her last name is Ghulam Winnie
and you can check out her TED talk if
you want which covers a lot of this the
last name is spelled bu o L AM WI and I
put a link in the show notes
awesome awesome yeah also I'm a GL
United org is the algorithm that Justice
League great thank you and I also wanted
to make sure to meet can you also tell
us because I know you touched on it but
can you explain a little bit more about
fat star I know this is a conference
that you're one of the ones who's
founded it know I'm in the program
committee and so Esme okay but the
person who will defeat the mean people
are Sorel Fiddler Suresh and solo and
Broca's so if you go to that conference
org
I'm just a big fan I always talk about
it I didn't I don't want people to think
that I founded this conference if you go
to a phat conference org you'll see like
who the editors are and who the program
chair is and and things like this yeah
so this was actually started as a
workshop at nips which is a top deep
learning conference and I believe Solan
Baracus and lore eats heart were the
original sort of creators a few years
back and that was before it was super
hot super hip to look at diversity and
policy and these kinds of issues
um they were really interested in
combining machine learning and and law
things like taking the Civil Rights Act
from 1964 and its notion of disparate
impact and then applying that
mathematically to something like
demographic parity
are really making those connections
between the legal world and the ML
mathematical world and it's it's really
sort of gotten tons of interest and
really sort of making some strides in
this space and so now it's become its
own conference and it switched from fad
ml to fad star as a kind of nod to
regular expressions
so it's fairness accountability and
transparency not just for machine
learning but for lots of other things as
well you know what I'm excited about
this conference is the fact that it's
interdisciplinary again I'm a huge fan
of interdisciplinary teams in general
and one of the things that that I
haven't seen before is laia isn't the
tutorials they have also these
translational tutorials so there's
specifically translational tutorials
which could be you know translating a
concept that is very well-known in one
specific area to people from a different
specific area so it could be translating
a very well-known machine learning
concept to lawyers or translating a very
well-known things in healthcare to
machine learning people so just kind of
start bridging this gap of knowledge
between that different groups so that we
can have some sort of common
understanding and common ground to start
working together this is great and I
hate to say it that we're pretty much
close to time because we could talk we
could talk about this for a while
clearly clearly I did want to ask you
both you know as we get close to
wrapping this out is there any last
things that you wanted to talk about in
terms of making sure people are aware of
anything you wanted to plug Margaret do
you have anything that comes to mind
right so if people are interested in
this space it's not just fairness that
that is sort of of interest I think to
people working on fairness it's its
ethics broadly and so there are also
ethics sort of conferences to be aware
of there was just one that was
co-located with Triple A I the AI ethics
and society conference coming up I'm
hosting one for NLP for language
processing specifically ethics and
natural language processing which will
be in New Orleans on June so there's
there's lots of other ways to get
involved if you'd like to take a look at
I think broadly with machine learning
right thank you Tim you yeah I want to
say something up
out hype and ethics and fairness I think
that we should all care about fairness
and ethics and diversity of course but
sometimes all of these words are used as
buzzwords and sometimes they're used for
PR purposes and sometimes there is for
image purposes so let me give you an
example if you have an all-male panel on
a i4f ethics or if social good or
something like this I have very little
faith that this is actually AI for
social good if you have an all-male team
or or very homogeneous team or you've
never graduated a female student or
something like this and now someone is
people are talking about ethics and
things like that so so I think people
say charity starts at home right so I
encourage everybody to think about our
our local our kind of our surroundings
and think about AI ethics and that in
that sense because it's not just like
you know raising money or creating the
next coolest fairness to kind of
algorithm it's also about including
people who are very well positioned to
work on these problems in your
surroundings in your immediate
surroundings yeah one thing I like to
look at is how many papers have been
published with women like what is your
track record for publishing with women
what is your track record for producing
projects with women this is one of these
things that gets overlooked but can also
be a sign of a lack of understanding or
inclusion of these kinds of other
viewpoints yeah and so this is this is
why I'm always so happy that meg is
always talking about accessibility as
well as part of the conversation around
ethics for example wonderful I wish we
had more time I really do this has been
a remarkable remarkable conversation and
I really thank you so much to both of
you tuna and Oh Margaret thank you for
joining us I really appreciate it very
much
we just have to do this again it's
important I know did you a part
next time we'll get joy again thank you
so much for joining us thank you to meet
and Margaret again for that great
interview I really wish we'd had more
time with them because it was a good
topic it's an important topic and it's
something that you know we can explore
in more detail in many ways as to meet
had mentioned and Margaret I mentioned
fat stars this conference that's coming
up next week and actually over the
weekend there was some great press and
coverage for a paper that both joined to
meet had worked on that's titled gender
shades intersectional accuracy
disparities and commercial gender
classification and they do this
basically assessment of facial
recognition systems and how good they
are in essence of being able to
recognize especially from a shade and
gender perspective and I use some
interesting techniques to assess that so
we'll include that in our show notes in
terms of links to that and all the links
to all the things that were referenced
while we were talking to them good stuff
so mark ask you this question question
of the week right it's always got to
kind of get a good question in there how
do you feel now our questions of the
week is as I mentioned you have this
chat with chaos any chat with Kiev is
wonderful it's all on Twitter but you
both were talking about is there GCP
service that handles cloud identity
aware proxy especially host via cloud
storage so mark is there is there okay
so if people aren't aware of cloud I
didn't do web proxy it's a proxy that
you can put in front of your
applications that controls whether
people have access basically through
their account logins it works with App
Engine standard app engine flexible
environment compute engine and
kubernetes engine but what k-f wants to
do is put it in front of Google Cloud
Storage for setting sides so the short
answer is unfortunately no but there are
a couple of interesting workarounds that
I think are worth discussing the first
one is and it's a bit of a cheeky answer
but you can always host static content
on App Engine itself there's no reason
why not I mean it's actually really
really easy to there's a lot of
opportunities there for putting static
content and if you're using some sort of
programming language and you want to mix
and match there's also opportunities to
do stuff like that as well so that's
that's always the thing so you could
always put the static content rather
than putting a Google hot storage you
could put it on App Engine and then put
cloud identity aware
proxy in front of that and you still get
a lot of the really great education you
get on Google Cloud storage the other
option is a open-source product that's
available on github and will have links
in the show notes
it's called weasel which is an
interesting name it of itself which is
basically a at the engine proxy for
basically files that you store on Google
Cloud storage so you could put this up
on App Engine then just change whatever
you need to change or host whatever you
need to host inside Google Cloud storage
and then put the identity where proxy in
front of that that application that runs
on it's called weasel yeah I died great
name yeah I don't know I don't know it's
a thing I'm gonna assume the naming has
something to do with it's like a weasels
make tunnels and it's like tunneling
through from App Engine to cloud storage
yeah I genuinely don't know but those
are the two options neither is is
exactly what KF is looking for but it
does give you some options to allow you
to do something similar to what it is
you're looking to do okay we're trying
to help yes okay so mark where you gonna
be in the next couple of weeks still
doing all the work that I can possibly
for GDC I'm pretty excited about that
it's GDC a thing GDC is a thing I'll
start talking a bit about more about
that but yeah we'll be having a booth
presence across Google on the floor so
be giving talks there there's some other
fun stuff we're also organizing as well
so as we get a bit closer and everything
gets super lockdown lots of preparation
lots of preparation nice what you I'm
gonna go to New York for fat star next
week and that's where you will be
finding me but outside of that I think
that covers us for this week all right
well Melanie thank you for joining me
once again on the episode this week
thanks mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
you